[音楽]
みなさんこんにちは川方珠美と申します
それではいきなりなんですが皆さんに質問があります
日本生まれのエンターテイメントって何だと思いますか
あーこれ返事来るまで私続けないんでん
えっ
花札花札渋いですねそうですね花札とか
まあよくあるのがカラオケとか言われるかと思うんですけれども私の作っている
リアル脱出ゲームというゲームも日本までのエンターテインメントの一つになります
リアル脱出ゲームはですね今年で生まれて10週
年を迎えました今までの総動員数が350万人になります
今ではですね世界中で展開しておりましてアメリカカナダヨーロッパの
えっとスペインフランスイギリスドイツ後アジア圏シンガポールとか中国とかで日本
だけではなく
展開しています
ん
そんなリアル脱出ゲームなんですが私2009年からスクラップと言う会社で
リアル脱出ゲームに携わるようになりまして
2015年の年末にロサンゼルスに引っ越してアメリ英語版
real escape game リアル脱出ゲームの英語版 real
escape game を作っています
pr
でたちなみにリアル脱出ゲーム知ってるよって人
ありがとうございます結構半数ぐらいありがとうございます
リアル脱出ゲーム遊んだこともあるよって人ありがとうございます
最前列にこんなにもありがとうございます
はいリアル脱出ゲームどんな感じかというと
はいこれあのスタジアムで行ったリアル脱出ゲームなんですけれどもこれ attack
on titan が進撃の巨人とのコラボレーションの脱出ゲームです
なんか脱出ゲームって言ったら部屋なのかなって思われるかもしれないですが部屋が気
じゃなくこういうスタジアムで行ったりとか
こんな感じでホールで行ったりとかもしています
でえっと私たちが作っているだしゲームなんですが
リアル脱出ゲームっていうのが一番有名なんですけれども別にリアル脱出ゲームだけを
作っているわけではありません
リアル脱出ゲームという名前がよく聞かれるようになっているんですがその他にも逆に
もう侵入が他のゲームとか
が最近はスパイになって遊べるゲームとか
えっとテーブルトーク rpg って知ってますか
そういうちょっとニッチな遊びなんですけどそのリアルテーブル等カール bpg
っていう遊びをしたりとかいろんな体験型のゲームを提供しています
で私たちはその体験型のゲームを物語性のある
インターラクティブなイベントを定義していますで今回はリアル脱出ゲームだけじゃ
なくて大金がたゲームについてお話ししたいと思います
私はゲームデザイナー
として今まで57公園の体験型ゲームを作ってきました
その体験型ゲームを作るにあたってどういうふうに考えているのかどういう思いでこの
体験型ゲームを作っているのかについてお話ししたいと思います
えっと体験型ゲームなんですけれどもまずはじめに作る時に私は
テーマからアプローチしますいろんな方法のアプローチがあって例えば
先にストーリー作って物語の起承転結
決める人がいたりとかえっとその案金プロジェクトに対する
あっ
たらしいゲームシステムを作ろうっていうアプローチで作る人がいるとかいたりするん
ですが
わたしは先にテーマを決めて作るようにしています
例えばなんですが各つて2013年に作ったゲームのテーマは家族愛でした
それは2013年に大阪で行った公演なんですけれども
なんで家族愛にしたかっていうと私が大阪出身なんですね
なのでえっと
実家が大阪にあるのでもしかしたら家族が遊びに来てくれるかなと思って
家族愛をテーマにした講演にしました
でそれは遊園地を使った野外の公園だったんですけれども
その家族愛をテーマにしてたんですがなんとうちの家族は暑いっていう理由できてくれ
ませんでした
はいいるのがはい実際にどんな悲しい結果になってしまったんですがあのゲームとして
どんなものだったかをご紹介したいと思います
銀その家族愛をテーマにしたゲームなんですがストーリー
はこんな感じでしたある少年がいてその少年のお母さんは病に伏しています
そのお母さんの病を治すためには
異世界にある魔法の薬を手に入れなくてはいけませんんその魔法の薬を手に入れるため
に
少年は冒険の旅に出ますその1
海の魔法の薬を手に入れるために少年は冒険の旅に出ます
その冒険の旅に出た時にですねアクシデントか起こってしまって少年は記憶をなくして
しまいます
記憶をなくした中でそのゲームが始まるんですけれども
謎を解き明かして
記憶を取り戻しどうにかしてお母さんの元に戻るというストーリーになっています
ただ謎を解いていくと魔法の薬もついに手に入るんですけど
魔法の薬を持ったまあまあ変えることができないことがわかります
魔法の薬と機会に家に帰る切符が手に入るんです
じゃあこれ
どうしたらいいのか
で普通に考えたらどうにもならないんですがそれまで間に入れたいろんな情報とか
謎を解いたり発想の転換をすることで
a
どうにかして魔法の薬を手に入れた状態で無事にお母さんのもとに帰ることができます
このように体験型ゲームには
いろんな視点から物事を見る力が含まれていると思っています
でありとあらゆるいろんな今ゲームデザイナーが10人ほど下ましていろんなゲームを
作ってるんですけど
すべての体験型ゲームにいろんな視点から物事を見る力が含まれています
ではいったいっでは具体的にどんなことなのか
お伝えしていければと思います
例えば小学校の時に謎などで
1+1はみたいなのあったの覚えてますか
1+1は兄と言ったらちょっとバカにされるみたいな答えは田んぼのたーーーーだよっ
ていうのがあったかと思います
そんな感じで1+に1アフ数式じゃないんだっていうのもいろんな視点から物事を見る
力の一つだと思います
じゃあ例えば具体的んじゃもう少し難しいだしてみましょう
これはてなに入るのなんだと思いますか
パク世界です早い
そうですこれはぁ-もうっていう思っちゃうともうダメなやつです
これはぁ-もうではありません
ハーモニカ
で読みますなのではてなに入るのは母です
こんな感じで謎を使ったりとか謎などを使ったりするといろんな視点から物事を考える
力をの練習になると思います
そんな私たちはそういうふうにいろんな視点で物事を考える力を皆さんにお伝えできれ
ばなぁと思ってるんですが私が次にテーマにしたいと思っている
またずっと結構思ってるんですけどこれからずっとテーマにしている体験型ゲームを
作る時の思いが教育をテーマにしたい
と思っています
なぜならば私は小さい頃ずっと世界はつまんないなぁって思っている子どもでした
いつまでたっても反故圧から入学案内届かないし
ファンタージェンもいけないしファンタージェンはもしかしたらドイツ
な可能性あるなと思ってクレーン王国ならいけるかなと思ったんですけど
クレオ報告文の入り口を探したけど全然クレヨン王国にも行けず
なんて世界はつまらないんだろうってずっと子供のこと
心を持っていました
ます
けどそのまま成長していって
小学校中学を言って大学も卒業して大学を卒業したあと本当にもうもううだつの上がら
ないフリーターが完成したんですけど本当に何者でもなく
何
すごい鬱々とした日々を過ごしていました
そんな時にふときっかけがあって私は視点を変えることができたんですがそれはきっと
ちょっと本を読んでたりとかといろんな
恵まれた出会いがあったりとかしたんですがその視点を変えた結果私の世界がぐっと
開けました
私の考えていた世界はこう変わりました
今まで何でもなかった私って
もしかしたら何でもできるんじゃないかなっ
なぜなぁは今までアン本当になるものでもなかったのでその大学卒業した後
そうだなと思ったんですよ
0で何に本当にこれ私にも何のために居るんだろうぐらいな気持ちだったんですけど
ゼロってことは100になる可能性があるということじゃないですか
ゼロってことは102何可能性がある
これ交換があるあれ世界超楽しいなと思って
その後一般大学卒業していろいろ
分ブラブラしてた頃なんですがありもしかしたらもしやりたいことがあるなら私今から
東大というかもしれないし
宇宙飛行士になってられるかもしれないしもしかしたスパイになれるかもしれないし
剽窃かに立って何でもなれるぞって思った瞬間
世界がすごく楽しい
よくなったんですね
なのでこの物事の視点を変える力っていうのを体験型のゲームを通して伝えていきたい
と思って
ではせっかく今日来ていただいたのでちょっと簡単なゲームを用意してみました
てみたくないですか
いやありがとうございます
はい
ではこんな g 6です
選ばれし者を見つけ出せなんとこの会場の中に合う伝説の選ばれし者がいます
みなさんこれから謎を解き明かして選ばれし者を見つけ出してください
ロールはこちらです
今んとですね横に82
いるかと思うんですがその8に横の人で1位です皆さんちょっと遠いですが頑張って
キュッと一緒に磨いてください
制限時間は5分
そして謎を解き明かすと選ばれし者が分かりますそしてちょっともう一つ必要な
アイテムがあるのでお渡しします
akira たから箱です一番左の列の人に
宝箱をお渡しします
皆さん受け取ってください
かあっ
8次のスライドで一番初めの難度が出ます
そのな事いて
次何するかがわかります
それでは選ばれし者を見つけだけえっ
この会場の中になんと選ばれし者が隠れています謎を全て解き明かして選ばれし者を
見つけ出してください制限時間は5分です
ゲームスタート
明けました
ni
ます
puni
エロそうな顔
ああああああああ
そういう形
あっは4 c 6 f ねーまだ6分経っていないのですがみなさんどうやら
選ばれし者を見つけ出したようなので一旦次に進みたいと思います
で1大雪を剥げていただきます
この謎をどうやって解くのか
結構早々に答えがパパって皆さんのほうから声が聞こえてきたんですがこの謎の解き方
は
こちらですねこのアーメイ
この本エンターキーこの矢印がポイントです
これを enter キーだと思ってください enter キーだとしたら開業する
開業じゃないですかエンターキポンてをしたらつまりここで開業します
でグって
この右側の部分が下に行くとこうなります
椅子のおらー
そうそして磯ノ浦皆さん見ていただきましたね
で椅子の裏から出てきたのがこういう神と後
懐中電灯みたいなライトだったかと思います
でこのままだったら溶けないんでこれをどうすればいいのかというと一番右端のマーク
ついてるのが一番あのキーになります
ますこのマークの順番通りにこの短冊を並べていきます
そうするとこうなります
さてこれをどうすればいいのかというと縦ではなく横読み左上から選んでいくと宝箱を
開けるための番号は67球になりますでは679
で宝箱を開けましょう宝箱を開けると中国は
あっこれあげしまったええっ
あなたの名前の証の裏をあなたの証の裏を照らせ
となっています
ではあなたの証とは何だったのかそれはあなた自身の名前です
受付で書いていただいたあなた自身の名前の裏を照らすと選ばれし者の証の文章が出て
きます
皆さん選ばれし者の証いてに入れましたか
はーい
さあここにいらっしゃる皆さん何と選ばれし者でした
ちなみにですねこれ昨日生成と準備して100パターンあります
ねうん何でよかったらあとでそのあブラックナイトなんですけどそのライトがブラック
ライトで他の人何書いてるのかとかちょっと見てみてください
はいでこれで皆さん自分が選ばれし者であることがわかったかと思います
選ばれし者でだとかそういうことを言われるのって簡単に品
んだいとかあなたはもやら晴れ c ものなんだよって言われるのは簡単なんですが
実際に今謎を解いて
インタラクティブに行動することにより手に入れる
っていうことによってより深い物語体験ができたんじゃないかと思います
なのでインタラクティブな物語体験をすることによりより深い物語体験ができる
そのことによりあなたが自分が選ばれし者だとか
このシチュエーション ax 選ばれし者っていうのにしてみましたが
宇宙飛行士だったりとかスパイだったりとかそういう体験を提供することができます
より深い
大金でそのことに現実世界でそういう体験を提供できることによりいろんな視点から
物事を見る力が手に入るんじゃないかなと思っています
そして今チームごとに
えっと謎解いてもらったんですが
多分謎の解き方の順序それぞれチームで違ったと思います
ある人が張って思いついたりとか
他のところが全然気づかないでいたりとかこれはもしかしたらもしかしたら宝箱の八尾
総当たりで開けたりとかいろんな
可能性がありますそれはあなただけの物語です
この体験型ゲームにおいてあなただけの物語においになります
この体験型ゲームにおけるあなただけの物語であなたが主人公になることができます
この現実世界で体験型をゲームをすることによりより深い物語体験没入感を選ぶ
得ることができるそしてまたその中であなただけの物語の主人公になることができます
さらにさっき言った謎を使うことによりなど自体が視点を変えるっていう素を含んでる
んでその視点を変えるっていう
練習にもなりますそういうことから私はこの体験型ゲームをいろんな視点から物事を
見る力を養うのにすごい最適なんじゃないかなと思っています
最後になりますが
私昔京都に住んでいたんですが
夜におうちに帰っている時に道端に
モニターが落ちてたんですねパソコンの
でその方にギターが道端に落ちてたんですけど
ちょうどコンビニの向かいぐらい落ちていい感じにこう照らされていてこれは何かあり
そうだなって思って
ただまぁもちろんゴミん可能性高いけど
なんかある可能性あるじゃないですか
なんで結構深夜がってそのひとりだったんですけどちょっとそのモニターの前に入って
ソンってやってみてデジタルワールドいけるかなって思ったんですけどまぁいもちろん
ここにいるんで生きてないですが実際にそんな感じであれこれもしかしたらって思った
方が世界は楽しいと思うんですね
なのでこういう体験型のゲームイベントを通していろんな視点
から物事を見る力を養ってもっといろんな人に世界は楽しいぞって子供とかに世界は
楽しいぞって思ってもらいたいなぁと思って私はこの体験型ゲームを作っています以上
ありがとうございました
[拍手]